We got a break yesterday from Manics sentence
fragments and verbal glitches.
And we actually heard for about 45 solid minutes
from former President Barack Obama at a rally
for Joe Biden in Philadelphia.
And it was refreshing only in so far as it
was normal English.
It was normal adult communication.
Now, you might say rally.
I hope that was safe.
It was very safe.
It was a drive and rally.
People sat in their cars.
And truly, you know, this is not Obama defecation.
This is just recognizing that we've been lacking
even the most basic ability for our president
to express himself and to think clearly for
a very long time.
And my audience who joined me live.
This event, by the way, far larger audience
for this Obama event than we've been seeing
for the Trump events that we've been covering
live.
The audience seemed to realize that, you know,
you don't have to agree with everything Barack
Obama did.
You don't have to agree with Barack Obama
on the way he negotiated Obamacare or drone
policy or many other things.
The wreck, the recognition seemed to be yesterday
that we as a country are desperate, in desperate
need of some normality, some normalization
of relationships with our allies, returning
to sanity to some degree.
And Barack Obama not only reminding us of
that, but brutally going after Donald Trump
during this rally.
Trump was triggered by it.
He started tweeting about Barack Obama almost
immediately.
Trump on his way to his own rally at the time,
tweeting a bizarre Bright Baat conspiracy
article about Barack Obama as Barack Obama
was speaking.
And we know that Donald Trump is very jealous
of Barack Obama, envious that Barack Obama
can speak coherently and he should be.
And I understand why.
Let's look at a few clips.
Barack Obama here making direct reference,
in fact, to Trump's retweeting of conspiracy
theories as this speech was going on.
Barack Obama actually a rather Donald Trump
retweeted a conspiracy article about Barack
Obama.
Here is Obama commenting on the conspiracies
and with Joe and Carmela at the helm.
You're not going to have to think about the
crazy things they said every day.
And that's worth a lot.
You're not going to have to argue about them
every day.
It just won't be so exhausting.
You might be able to have a Thanksgiving dinner
without having an argument.
You'll be able to go about your lives knowing
that the president is not going to read tweet
conspiracy theories about secret cabals running
the world or or that Navy SEALs didn't actually
kill bin Laden.
Think about that.
The president of the United States retweeted
that.
Imagine.
What?
And then continuing on to point out the cartoonish
absurdity of Donald Trump promising to protect
preexisting conditions while trying to get
rid of Obamacare, which protects preexisting
conditions.
You know, Republicans love to say right before
an election that they'll protect your preexisting
conditions.
Now, Joe and I actually protected your policies
to make sure people with preexisting conditions
could get health insurance and have coverage.
We did it through something called the Affordable
Care Act, a.k.a. Obamacare.
And Republicans try to repeal or undermine
it more than 60 times.
And when they've been asked about that, they
keep on promising we're going to have a great
replacement.
They said it's common.
It's been common in two weeks for the last
10 years.
Whereas whereas this great plan to replace
Obamacare, they've had 10 years to do it.
There is no plan.
They've never had one.
Well said there.
Then Barack Obama weighing in on the undisclosed
Chinese bank account of Donald Trump and pointing
out exactly as I did imagine if it had been
Obama or Hillary with undisclosed Chinese
bank accounts.
We know that he continues to do business with
China because he's got a secret Chinese bank
account.
How is that possible?
A secret Chinese bank guelke blessing.
Can you imagine if I had a secret Chinese
bank account when I was running for reelection?
You think you think, Mike, you think Fox News
might have been a little concerned about that?
They would have called me Beijing, Barry,
as I've pointed out before.
It's actually worse than this.
If Barack Obama had done any of the hundreds
of scandalous things that Donald Trump has
done.
It would have been a multi month story with
demands for congressional investigations,
which if Republicans controlled the House
and Senate at the time, they would have gotten
congressional investigations about a hypothetical
Beijing Bery Chinese bank account in this
next clip.
You can actually hear the exact aspiration
in Barack Obama's voice pointing out that
Donald Trump is running Medicaid right now
and trying to kick people off of it.
And many other backwards things are going
on.
And our water is right now run by an energy
lobbyist that gives polluters free rein to
dump unlimited poison into our air and water.
The Labor Department that's supposed to protect
workers and their rights.
Right now, it's run by corporate lobbyists
who's declared war on workers guts.
Protections to keep essential folks safe during
a pandemic.
Makes it easier for big corporations to shortchange
them on their wages.
The Interior Department that's supposed to
protect our public lands and wild spaces are
our wildlife and our wilderness.
And right now, that's run by an oil lobbyist
who's determined to sell them to the highest
bidder.
You've got the Education Department that's
supposed to give every kid a chance, and that's
run by a billionaire who guts rules designed
to protect students from getting ripped off
by for profit colleges and step on students
looking for loan relief in the middle of an
economic collapse.
I mean, the person who runs Medicaid right
now is doing their best to kick people off
of Medicaid.
Barack Obama very, very astutely pointing
out here, much like Bernie Sanders has pointed
out, much like Noam Chomsky has pointed out.
We make incremental change for the better
and then we make another incremental change
and then another.
And the fact that we don't get 100 percent
of what we want right away is not a good reason
not to vote.
It means we've got a vote and then get some
change and then vote some more and then get
some more change and then keep on voting until
we get it right.
This is very well said.
This is a point I've been making for a while
now.
I know that there are people who will hear
that and they will say that's neo liberal
status quo trash.
And to them, I would say, as I've said before,
give me the receipts, show me the evidence
that the acceleration ist ideas actually achieve
better results than what Barack Obama is talking
about here.
I care about reality, not about ideology.
And I have not found such facts.
So overall, very well done.
I think this could actually pay dividends
tonight during the second and final presidential
debate.
I expect Trump will be extra furious and likely
to self-destruct as a result of Barack Obama
now getting involved.
It's not about Barack Obama being perfect.
It's not about Barack Obama being the progressive
dream.
It's just a desire to return to more normal
times.
When our elected officials understood and
accepted science, when our elected officials
maintained normal relationships with other
countries and weren't a global laughingstock.
Barack Obama will be rallying for Joe Biden
on Saturday in Florida.
Very important.
And I do actually think that whatever your
thought is about Barack Obama in analyzing
the election from an objective standpoint,
I think this very much helps Joe Biden remember
that George W. Bush was not out there campaigning
for John McCain, was not was not well liked
enough to be able to do it.
George W. Bush was certainly not out there
campaigning for Donald Trump in 2016.
And the fact that it is so obvious that this
is an advantage to Joe Biden tells us a lot
about the importance of job of Barack Obama
being out there doing it.
We'll have more of this and clips on our Instagram
page, David Pakman show on Instagram